so let's start with some algebra so
there are nice simple equations like X
plus 1 equals 5 course it's not too hard
to solve that equation we get x equals 4
now this is an equation in whole numbers
and we solved it in whole numbers pretty
soon if you write down equations you get
things you can't solve in whole numbers
if the equation had been X plus 6 equals
5 there's no whole number solution to X
I would need minus 1 for that so that's
x equals minus 1 so I need to introduce
negative numbers to do that that's good
but after all we might face an equation
like 2x plus 1 equals 0 so we need some
fractions as well to keep go on solving
these equations after a while you begin
wondering why you didn't multiply X's
together you get polynomial equations so
a polynomial is something like a
constant times X to the n plus another
number times X to the n minus 1 plus bla
bla bla equations that I've got things
to the power right there not even
equations they're really functions if I
have a function f of X then I talk I
could solve an equation but an equation
needs an equal sign so f of x equals 0
is an equation and I talk about a
solution but if I have just a function f
of X then I can talk about a root of the
function that's the same thing as a
solution so I have have the habit of
alternating between talking about roots
and and solutions so I don't want to
confuse anybody let's look at an
equation if we had x squared minus 1
equals 0 X could be plus 1 that's a
solution but there's another solution 2x
equals minus 1 if I have other
polynomial equations though it's not so
easy to find solutions for instance a
simple one would be x squared equals 2
well there's no rational number that
solves that equation that's something
the Greeks discovered they considered a
deep
philosophical mystery but now of course
we just write x equals square root of 2
and there's another one if you believe
that there's a square root of 2 then you
surely believe there's a minus square
root of 2 so that's another solution so
again I have two solutions which is
pretty nice so I could go on that way
unfortunately I quickly hit equations
that don't have solutions in real
numbers something like x squared plus 1
equals 0 has no real number solutions
because if I put in a real number X this
is always has a positive square and when
I add 1 it's even more positive so I can
never get 0 so this point is begin nice
to begin graphing equations for instance
if f of X is x squared plus 1 and when X
is 0 I get the value of 1 so I put a 1
there and when X is for example 1 then
this would be 2 so I'd be up here when X
is 2 it's 4 so it's up here somewhere
and everybody probably has seen this as
a parabola so it doesn't have any roots
it doesn't have any any values of X
which make the value of f of X be 0 you
can see that from the picture because a
solution would be a place where the
graph crossed the x-axis in other words
where Y was 0 this line is where y
equals 0 so for a function to have a
root or an equation of a solution the
graph of the function has to cross the
x-axis it's like an electric fence or a
magic special magic law a magic line
right there is one kind of polynomial
equation that always has a root in real
numbers and that's the case when F has
odd degree so every polynomial has a
degree in this case it's in exponent on
the highest power if you have a
polynomial odd degree
well this one was if even degree and
that turns out in some way to be why it
didn't have a root if let's take one of
odd degree if we took for instance the
function f of x equals x well f of x
equals x of course is of odd degree and
the graph of that is just a straight
line that goes through the origin you
can see it has a solution when x equals
0 but I could do fancy
things I could say f of x equals x maybe
x squared times X minus 1 what does that
look like well I can see from the way I
wrote it that f of x equals 0 has two
roots at x equals 1 and the other one is
at x equals 0 and the graph is going to
look it turns out something like this
and I'll explain how I knew that in a
second but I see the root and I see that
there's a really robust root there this
one I'll sort of almost missed if I'd
move down just a little bit it wouldn't
have been a root anymore for instance if
I put here minus 1 then this whole
picture would move down by one but it
would still have a root here and this is
really a robust picture somehow so that
that's there's a theorem behind that
mathematicians love to write the word
theorem especially when they can prove
what they're about to write any
polynomial and here I mean with real
coefficients of odd degree that's what
the coefficients that are about to graze
the polynomial the polynomial has odd
degree that's right begin something like
X to the fifth plus seven X to the
fourth plus something else of odd degree
has at least one real root this odd
exponent is going to be the key that's
right just from that I'm going to show
you that there's some X which when you
put it in plug it in here it gives zero
as the answer that's pretty amazing that
you can say that just from knowing that
little piece of the polynomial anyway
this is a proof that really explains
something I think I'm going to graph the
polynomial you might ask me how can you
graph the polynomial if you don't know
anything about it but I'm going to do it
anyway I'm going to assume that a is
positive just for the sake of argument
to make make one picture but there would
be an exactly corresponding picture of a
were negative and I want to find a value
of X where Y is zero and of course that
means a place where the graph will cross
the x axis the x axis is really the
graph of y equals zero as that magic
point on the y axis called
zero and we want to get there you I ask
why zero why not take y equals seven as
your goal and we could do that to
exactly the same proof would do that too
I want to graph it well unfortunately
don't even know where to start how can i
graph a function that I know so little
about but I do know one thing a positive
number to an odd power is positive but a
negative number to an odd power is a
negative number and if I make the
absolute value of the number really
really big then I get a really really
big number and if the number is positive
it's really really really positive
number if it's negative it's really
really negative let's say a and B and C
and all the constants of this are pretty
small
they're bounded by something anyway and
I take X to be a hundred times as big as
the biggest constant then X and let's
say the exponents 5 just for the sake of
argument then X to the fifth power will
be a hundred times larger than X to the
fourth power because I had I multiplied
it on extra-time by X so this first term
will be enormous ly larger than anything
else and in fact if i graph this
function you won't even see the
influence of the other other terms on
the scale that I'm trying to draw here
basically this first term is going to
dominate it's going to be the most
important term and so I can at least
approximate what I'm doing
especially when X is large just by
thinking about the first term of course
when X is small all bets are off I can't
say a thing
but when X is large I understand so
let's take X large let's take X a
hundred times larger than all the other
coefficients I'll just pretend it's a
hundred for the sake of argument so big
X how big X X big and I'm going to say
absolute x big and this is the way a
mathematician would write that absolute
x much bigger than zero so minus 100
plus 100 those are good candidates so if
X is big X is a hundred then X to this
positive power will be much bigger than
any of the other exponents and it'll be
about a hundred to the 2n plus one
that's a big number
I'm going to draw it up here and you
have to think that the y-axis is is a
really different scale than the x axis
that point I can put in with some
confidence I don't know exactly where it
is pretty close it's why it's way out
there right now if I take X to be minus
100 then in for the same reason now I
get enormous absolute value for X to the
fifth or X to the 2n plus 1 but 2 n plus
1 is odd so I'll get an enormous
negative value so that was the first
point of the proof was that I can I can
say something about these way-out values
the second point of the proof and there
are only two is that a graph of a
function like this which is called a
continuous function can be drawn without
lifting my pencil so I'm going to start
drawing I don't know where the graph
really goes but I'm going to draw as if
I did it goes somehow and when I get to
this point oh my gosh it has to cross
the x-axis to get up there well all
right here we go
it just crossed that's a root of the
equation and it goes on somehow I don't
have any idea really where the root is
it might be on the left it might be on
the right but in order to get from here
to here without lifting your pencil you
simply have to draw a line that crosses
but you can't walk from Mexico to Canada
without going through the US right right
of course you could swim around and you
or you maybe who could dig a tunnel and
so we might have a little worried how do
we really know that there wasn't a
little tunnel just at that place maybe
the real numbers just opened up like the
Red Sea and let the red thing through
well that's a really basic point about
the real numbers and it wasn't
completely understood until Dedekind I
think in the nineteenth century but you
have to decide what you think the real
numbers are if I took the rational
numbers for instance suppose I said I
don't know what the real numbers are but
let's do with the rational numbers and
said this wouldn't have worked because
there for example X cubed minus 2 has no
real roots
that's an odd degree polynomial and
that's because this line would slip
through the rational numbers where
there's no rational number and even
adding square roots and cube roots
wouldn't be enough you'd have to add a
lot of roots
this work so how do we know there isn't
a hole there and this is one of the
great ideas in mathematics that's due to
debt again and it was a definition of
real numbers in terms of rational
numbers and it's so nice that I have to
tell you about it even though you might
already be convinced that there's no
holes in the real numbers so I'm going
to draw the rational numbers like this
there are a lot of rational numbers but
they're also lots of holes as we've seen
and then it can have the idea that what
a real number really is is a way of
dividing the rational numbers into two
parts so here let's say this is going to
be a real number
hey and etic and said that what a really
is is the set of rationals rational
numbers less than a together with the
set of rational numbers greater than a
so these two sets tell where a is in the
real numbers and the reason there are no
holes left is if there were a whole I
would just find I would just define it
to be the number which is the two sets
all the numbers the rational numbers
less than that number and all the
numbers greater than that number so I've
defined holes out of existence this way
it's a really funny term really it's a
great trick this is saying the
definition of David is the left side of
his body plus the right side of his body
it's worse than that it's saying that's
the space on the left of me together
with a space on the right of me and it
tells you just as little about me as
this tells you about the real number
that's sitting there but it's a it's a
good existence kind of proof or a really
construction this is the sort of thing
that people study in maybe the junior
year course in mathematics or philosophy
or philosophy as these are called
Dedekind cuts and it's really important
idea in mathematics
I want to graph this function I want to
tell you what happens when I buy X and I
want to find a point here which or at
least to convince you that there is a
point a blue point which will go to zero
on the red side